i think the question we need to ask
ourselves in india right now is do we
really want to be on the side of the
russians given the fact that you know
the aggression is is very um you know
it's very distasteful
friendship is the
key word to describe the history of our
relations our meeting today takes place
in a difficult international environment
[Music]
russia is a major arm supplier
for india there's this kind of a
tightrope walk that india seems to be
doing in terms of of not wanting to
annoy the russians too much we have
become closer to russia because of the
kind of nationalism that you know that
is behind the russian invasion of
ukraine i think there's a certain kind
of a resonance to the kind of
nationalism that we have
which is very dominant in this country
right now but
you know the times have changed
the russia of today is not the soviet
union of early times that we had a very
kind of a gordon relationship
[Music]
i think this is more short-termist
rather than you know having a long-term
view because the long-term implications
to be honest with you i don't think have
really been factored in in terms of this
tightrope walk as i called it that we're
doing with not wanting to annoy the
russians too much
the west is looking at this as a kind of
a battle between democracies against
autocracies
and india being a country which has
prided itself on its democracy and which
is actually one of our great successes
so far
the fact that we are seen to be aligned
with autocracies
uh like russia and china is
i think a major concern for for western
powers
i mean i think at this moment what's
important is to kind of visualize a kind
of a long-term
understanding of where we see ourselves
in the world
i hope we don't get to that situation
where many years later we really kind of
asked ourselves this question was this
really what we wanted